so you're the leader of a third world
country like sri lanka you are adored by
your 22 million loyal followers and you
have the entire country under your
control but that is just not enough
sure you're in a position of power but
your salary sucks what good is power if
you just leave your position broke how
are you going to feed your family and
fly them on private jets
you are the leader of this fine nation
you deserve to get paid what you're
worth and the only way to do that is to
steal as much money as humanly possible
while you're still in office got it see
unlike power you get to keep the money
you pocket as president once you leave
office and since most developing nations
don't really have checks and balances or
transparency over why decisions are made
or how money is used funneling money
into your own pocket while turning your
homeland into a failed state is very
doable if you know the right tactics and
that's exactly what happened to sri
lanka the people of sri lanka have the
numbers and they've had enough
the ruling rajapaksa dynasty bled the
country drive for more than a decade
they stashed away billions of dollars
outside the country while they were in
power and when the people finally had
enough they simply packed up their bags
and fled the country to never be seen
again has left the country along with
members of his family the president
gotta buy a rajpaksa has now fled the
country
rajapaksa and his wife have fled the
country on a military jet and since they
store their billions out of reach
outside the country they get to now
spend the rest of their lives living the
billionaire lifestyle while sri lanka
completely collapses
how many billions did they make off what
do you ask well sri lankan investigators
said they found more than 10 billion
dollars kept offshore under the names of
family and friends of the dynasty that
is 10 billion that the family managed to
quietly siphon out of the country while
they were in office it's more than the
entire country has in cash so as you can
see the russia pakistan family were
masters at this game
in the media people cried that this was
outrageous sri lanka has fallen it's all
this family's fault but you and i know
different you and i both know that this
is just how things typically work in
developing nations and if you're the
leader of one of these developing
nations everyone else is doing it so you
might as well get in on the action and
this is the step-by-step guide you've
been waiting for
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power
you can't get out of this game either
way so instead of being a victim why not
learn to be a better player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to stay dangerous and let's
learn how to milk your country dry
[Music]
the reason why the rajapaksa family made
off with so much money is because they
buried the country in debts and the
people that gave sri lanka all this debt
they weren't doing it out of the
kindness of their hearts they profited
from it too the more they shackle third
world countries in debt the more
leverage they have overlung when these
countries can't pay back their debts oh
well i guess you're just gonna have to
give us all your natural resources i
guess you just have to let us build this
military base on your land this strategy
of shackling poor countries in debt is
so effective that there's a term for
these people economic hitmen i learned
about this from the book confessions of
an economic hitman by john perkins and
it completely blew my mind it's an
insane book that everyone should read
and the great thing is you can listen to
this audiobook for free right now when
you sign up for audible with the link
below the audiobooks i've listened to on
audible have completely changed my life
and that is no exaggeration that's why
i've been using audible for the last
four years and why i will continue using
them until the day i die if you're not
listening to audiobooks you're really
missing out where in a recession is
probably just gonna get worse over the
next one or two years and the best hedge
against a recession are your skills
because while a job can be taken away
from you your skills and knowledge can't
and the most convenient way to learn
skills is with audiobooks because you
can listen to them while you're doing
other stuff and the best platform for
audiobooks is without a doubt audible
it's got the largest selection of titles
once you sign up for audible you get to
choose one of those titles every single
month from their entire catalog and if
you have amazon prime you get to start
out with two free titles instead of just
one you literally have nothing to lose
and everything to gain so pause the
video and get 30 days of audible for
free by going to audible.com jaketrain
or texting jake trent the 500-500 that's
audible.com jake tran with the link
below or text jake trent to 500 500
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video
in most developing nations there are
really only two ways to become president
no matter how democratic the process is
supposed to be either you come from a
wealthy respected well-established
family or you people please you appeal
to the masses and in the case of the
rajapaksa family that ruled sri lanka
they used both tactics you see the
rajapaksas had been wealthy and
well-known in sri lanka long before they
became the ruling family they originally
made their money from coconut and rice
farming but then came the sri lankan
civil war which lasted for more than 25
years from 1983 to 2009. in a nutshell a
rebel group named the tamil tigers waged
war against the government for
discriminating against them and their
people and that's where the rajapaksa
family really made a name for itself
in 2005 mahindo rajapaksa became the
president of sri lanka thanks to his
family's good name
not long after he appointed his younger
brother gotabaya as the country's
minister of defense
together the rajapaksa brothers carried
out a ruthless campaign against the
tamil tigers during which many people
accused them of crimes that we can't
talk about on this channel long story
short the tamil tigers were officially
defeated in 2009 and the two rajapaksa
brothers they became national heroes for
bringing peace to the nation
for 10 years mahinda rajapaksa ruled sri
lanka that was until 2015 when a new
leader from a different family was
chosen but for the rajapaksa family that
just wasn't acceptable they had gotten a
taste of power of money of absolute
control over millions of people's lives
and their thirst was nowhere near
satisfied so in 2018 gotabaya rajapaksa
announced his decision to run for
president backed by his status as a sri
lankan war hero and defense minister and
with all his family's money taking power
would be a piece of cake but gotabaya
had big plans for his time as president
and he wasn't going to leave anything to
chance so he went on a people-pleasing
spree like nothing in the world had ever
seen before and one of his biggest
campaign promises
massive tax cuts for everyone
his plan worked like magic
no one in sri lanka asked how the
government planned to pay for health
care school or infrastructure after
these tax cuts no one cared that
gotabaya rajapaksa was promising them
something without considering the
consequences no no no for everyday sri
lankans who worked hard to earn their
money tax cuts were a dream come true so
in november 2019 gotabaya rajapaksa
became president of sri lanka and in the
next three years he would give you our
power grabbing money hungry leader of a
third world country the perfect action
plan for taking your people for every
last cent they have
a single president can steal a lot of
money but an entire government of
corrupt officials they can take a
country for everything it's worth that's
why to really make the most of your time
and power and steal as much money as
possible you're gonna need help that's
why you gotta promote as many family
members as possible into positions of
power you want to flood key government
positions with your bloodline this
should be easy as long as you distract
the people with something they love like
tax cuts new developments or fancy
sounding social programs as long as the
people are focused on all the quote
unquote good you're doing they won't
notice you quietly filling the
government with your goons and once you
control the country's budget every last
cent of its money is yours for the
taking
in the first two years of gotabaya
rajapaksa's presidency his brother basil
was appointed finance minister
his other brother jamal was made a
cabinet minister and almost every other
cousin nephew niece aunt and uncle was
put in some position of power in the
government by the time gotabaya ran out
of relatives to employ the rajapaksa
family controlled around 75 percent of
the sri lankan government's budget they
created a monopoly not a business
monopoly but a government monopoly and
thanks to their war hero status after
the civil war everyone was happy that
sri lanka was being ruled by pretty much
one family i mean if the brothers were
good enough to beat the tamil tigers
obviously having the whole family
involved in politics would be great for
the country and economy
let's be honest most third world
countries don't exactly have billions of
dollars lying around for you to steal
and unlike america you can't just print
more money because that would tank the
value of your currency which leaves you
with a bit of a problem how are you
gonna get rich if there's no money to
steal
that's where our guy gotabaya comes in
with the winning strategy again you see
in 2020 he was faced with the same
dilemma
the tax cuts he promised had cut the
government's revenue by 25
and then kovid came along and shut down
the tourism industry which was
responsible for 12 percent of the
country's gdp
sri lankans working abroad also stopped
sending money back home all of this
meant that there really wasn't a lot of
money lying around for his family to
steal or misuse
but luckily that's where the magic of
debt comes in
see it's super easy for third world
nations to get money from banking
institutions like the international
monetary fund or imf the world bank or
china you simply go to them and say our
people are suffering we don't have any
food or infrastructure you need to give
us as much money as possible for
developments and social programs
you say these projects are going to take
your country to the next level and
you'll be able to pay them all back with
interest no problem
and then they'll write you a fat check
thank you
why because these people aren't giving
you money out of the kindness of their
hearts they're giving you a loan that
you have to pay back with interest and
when you can't repay them they tighten
the noose around you your country falls
under their influence their control
which is what happens to a lot of
developing countries that take these
loans
but you don't care if you leave your
country shackled in debt so you take as
many loans as you can and put the money
into your pocket
but the problem is you can't be that
brazen about it you actually have to
look like you tried to use the money for
good or else the masses will revolt so
here's what you gotta do
once you get the loans you use that
money to pay for massive construction
projects like buildings hospitals and
airports the key here is that the
companies you pay to build these
projects are owned by none other than
your friends and family
now you may be wondering but i want
money in my pocket not just my friends
and family calm down calm down you
simply make a deal with them that you
can control over your cut of these funds
that get paid
it doesn't matter if the bank account is
under their name and not yours in fact
it should be under their name and not
yours all that matters is that you're
able to spend the money as if it was
your own
if that strategy draws a bit too much
attention you can easily make a deal
with an outside business to do the work
for you but just arrange an under the
table deal to make sure they secretly
pay you a cut of the money you give them
that way a chunk of every payment you or
your family pays from the government's
account for these developments makes its
way back into your pocket
and since your family controls the
country's entire budget you never have
to struggle to get approval for payments
or projects because you're all equally
corrupt and equally happy to bleed the
country's coffers dry
the more debt you rack up the more
pointless buildings you construct the
more money you stand to make and this is
exactly what the rajapaksa dynasty did
in sri lanka by 2019 foreign debt was
around 42
of the country's gdp that meant the sri
lankan government would have to use
almost half of all the money every
person in sri lanka made in a year to
pay back its debt
this debt was used to import food and
medicine
and even though it seems like a lot the
country's debt was manageable
that was until gotabaya rajapaksa got
involved
he racked up the country's debt as fast
as possible from china or the imf while
claiming it was for some big development
or to help uplift the people when in
reality he was using it to build vanity
projects like airports and unused
hospitals all developments sri lanka
didn't really need but it made the
government look good
and just two years later in 2021
sri lanka's foreign debt ballooned to
119
of its gdp
this dude borrowed 56 billion dollars in
two years
and you know what that means a good
chunk of that 56 billion went straight
into their pockets
that meant even if the government took
all the money the entire country made in
a year it still wouldn't be enough to
pay off its debt
so now that you've extracted as much
money as you can from your country now
all you have to do is find somewhere to
hide all that cash so no one can ever
trace it back to you
[Music]
as you're bleeding your country dry you
want to make sure all that money flows
to offshore accounts using all sorts of
fake shell companies and bank accounts
that way it will be nearly impossible to
trace the money back to you and you'll
be able to enjoy your stolen millions in
peace
the great thing is that there's an
entire industry that specializes in
helping people like you who value
privacy set these things up it's just a
quick google search away but beware
sometimes there are leaks that happen
where you will get exposed for doing
stuff like this
like what happened to the rajapaksa
family
they had been involved in sri lankan
politics since the 1940s but thanks to a
decades-long civil war and the fact that
the family ran the government for more
than 10 years there's no real record of
any of their actual wealth
with family members in every powerful
position the rajapaks has managed to
remove all the checks and balances that
would have kept track of how much they
were really worth
and they did all of this
they set up the shell companies they set
up the offshore accounts
but then in 2021 the pandora papers
dropped pandora papers as they're being
called the world leaders powerful
politicians even drug dealers revealed
in almost 12 million files it was a
massive data leak exposing thousands of
offshore accounts and their owner's
details
which also included accounts held by the
rajapaksa family worth tens of millions
of dollars
just one of the family's lower level
government members was reportedly worth
160 million dollars
and there's no way all of it came from
their coconut and rice farming
no matter how good you are hiding
corruption it's only a matter of time
until one of your pesky annoying
subjects figures out something's not
right it doesn't matter how well you
cover your tracks eventually people are
gonna notice billions of dollars
evaporating into thin air and that's
when you gotta go on the defensive
while sri lanka's foreign currency was
running out thanks to all the debt
gotabaya racked up and all the useless
projects he started the president did
his best to pretend everything was
perfectly fine
he got the sinhalese buddhist community
to openly voice their support for him
while blasting state-owned media
channels with all the good work the
government was doing
sri lanka ranks 127 out of 180 countries
for freedom of the press so getting the
media to stick to the government's
narrative wasn't that hard and when that
wasn't enough to stop people from
realizing the country was running out of
money he just told the banks to print
more he didn't care that printing more
money would mean that inflation would
skyrocket he knew this wouldn't last
forever so you might as well milk it
while you can
but then sri lanka's foreign currency
reserves started running out and that
was a problem he couldn't fix with any
of his usual tactics
you see countries with debt from the imf
or world bank have to pay that debt back
in dollars not in sri lankan rupees
but since sri lanka was now importing
more than it was exporting the kovan 19
pandemic had completely stopped tourists
from visiting and bringing their foreign
currency with them and the country was
facing billions of dollars in repayments
all the government's foreign reserves
were running low
by 2021 there was only 1.8 billion
dollars in foreign reserves left
it got so bad that in a desperate move
to stop spending the country's dollars
president gotabaya actually banned
fertilizer imports to sri lanka
he told everyone he wanted sri lanka to
become the world's first country with
100
organic farms so noble
but the truth was sri lanka was running
out of dollars and euros to pay for
imported goods and fertilizer was one of
the first imports to be cancelled
unfortunately instead of preventing an
economic catastrophe banning fertilizer
imports was the straw that broke the
camel's back
the country's rice production dropped by
50 percent
rice is a staple food for millions of
families in sri lanka and just a few
months after the ban the government was
forced to start importing rice to feed
the people so banning fertilizer had
actually just made the country's
problems worse
and then russia invaded ukraine pushing
up the prices of everything from fuel to
flower
again not great news for a country that
has to import almost everything
the noose was slowly tightening around
the sri lankan economy and it wasn't
long before things really started to
spiral into chaos
[Applause]
if you're a good strategist even while
your country is going down in flames
there's a chance you can ride out the
storm hundreds of presidents around the
world have stolen millions from their
countries while still keeping the
people's faith in their government
unfortunately gotabaya rajapaksa did not
have that skill
if you push your country to the brink of
collapse and your subjects start
revolting it's time to pack up your bags
and get out before the pitchforks reach
you by the end of 2021 sri lanka was
running out of everything
food fuel electricity medicine even
paper that schools needed to print exams
on in just a few months 500 000 sri
lankans fell into poverty because
everything had to be imported and the
insane fuel prices meant things like
food and gas became completely
unaffordable by 2022 the real inflation
rate in sri lanka sat around 132
and then just as it seemed like things
couldn't get any worse the government
announced that all fuel sales in sri
lanka would be suspended too
suddenly no one could fill up their cars
planes were grounded and then the power
outages started
the sri lankan people had had enough in
early 2022 thousands of people took to
the streets in protest and if your
country reaches this point there's
really only one thing you can do pack up
your stuff and run
in april 2022 the sri lankan government
announced it didn't have enough money to
pay back its debt and it would be
defaulting on all 51 billion dollars of
it
and in may it announced the country only
had around 50 million dollars in foreign
currency left
50 million dollars to buy fuel
medication food and essential supplies
enough was enough the rajapaksas had
once been sri lankan national heroes
now the people wanted their heads on a
stick
so they started storming the homes owned
by the rajapaksa family it got so bad
that mahinda rajapaksa the country's
prime minister had to be evacuated by
the military while president gotabaya
was spotted fleeing the country on a
military jet
on july 10 2022 just as gotabaya fled
the country thousands of protesters
stormed the presidential palace
they were filmed drinking the
president's alcohol swimming in his pool
and not even the sri lankan military
cared enough to stop them for the people
it felt like a victory but the reality
the rajapaksas took their millions with
them when they fled they are set for
life
leaving everyday sri lankans to deal
with the fall of their country
having corrupt leadership may have been
one of the reasons sri lanka is in
crisis right now but there are many
other ways to destroy a country's
economy in future
and no one knows that better than
america
for centuries the american government
secretly toppled anti-american
presidents around the world to replace
them with american friendly puppet
leaders
but the funny thing is most of the time
instead of getting better after the coup
the country's actually descended into
chaos leaving things way worse than they
were before and the best example of that
is iran
in 1951 iran elected a democratic prime
minister named mohammed mosaddegh
unfortunately for them america didn't
like mosul dig all that much because he
planned on kicking american and british
businesses out of the country
so just two years after becoming
president the cia orchestrated a coup
that forcibly removed him from office
and replaced him with one of their
puppets
but there was no way america could ever
have anticipated the consequences of
that one little act of oppression
the 1953 iranian coup was the first
domino to fall directly or indirectly
resulting in some of the worst terror
attacks in history but here's the thing
going into all the details on iran and
terror attacks will definitely get
demonetized so instead we released it as
a private full-length documentary only
available to members of this channel
all you have to do to watch this full
documentary right now is hit that join
button below
once you do you'll also have access to
all our other videos on topics like cia
black sites and the enhanced
interrogation techniques used in those
black sites then we have one on
everyone's favorite private island owner
every jepsteen and so much more
people spend years of their life and
tens of thousands of dollars to attend
university only to leave not knowing
anything about how the world really
works
but by becoming a member you'll get
access to all this insider info for only
five dollars a month
and trust us it's way more entertaining
than university lectures
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
and we will personally refund you for
your first month after your first month
there is no refund
so there's been a lot of coverage of the
sri lanka crisis already on youtube but
no one has really attacked it from this
angle so i really wanted to make this
video and you know how everyone in this
world is pretty much out there powering
just like we saw in this video but
everyone seems to be afraid of admitting
it in public well that is the point of
this channel we make documentaries on
money power war and crimes that you can
learn from these power games instead of
becoming a victim to it so if that
sounds enticing to you click the
subscribe button below because we make
multiple videos just like this one every
single week for free but that is going
to wrap it up thanks for being part of
the watch the n club stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you